they can get done what they didn't get done last
year this time around and we're underway well as
Fargo Center Carter har we'll see that [__] up
for Travis sanheim Frost back to katees and frost
to the point San Morgan Frost takes it back takes
the shot save made rebound f it bounced off of
him pel able to get there could not clear sanim
is there quickly across did you say good bloke
yeah I did yeah that's my English coming out wow
my English Heritage JJ yeah I didn't expect the
bloke in the pre-season but there we go durando
for the Islanders move it back to the point that
shot goes wi boxes this way and off the post goes
dando he beat hard across but couldn't nail it now
lton looking for the Pucket hops over his stick
at the other end of the ice he pivots with it he
was all by himself his cing fast blocked off
by ran pinno and now dos it across Bon will
backand in I think he got B on that one I don't
think I'm going to get a blo from B this year
Well BL I'm not sure if he's French Canadian or
American or what who knows what B is deflecting
that one wide from Insight nice Rescue of the PCH
by York navigates his way back around behind The
Islander net Banks it back out and I took his
eye off the puck and look out the other way now
it's a breakway flying in on go is Carson Coleman
scores turnover by the Flyers kman takes advantage
and the Islanders have the one- nothing lead Here
Comes sanheim took his head up just for a second
Puck bounces over it and here's kman there's the
fake shot right there Carter heart went down and
almost got his pad over there right to the post
to kind of seal that offload the only way you're
going to score if you do that is if you elevate
the puck but soon to give them some youth he turns
with the puck here goes across over wall back to
Dobson and now do for Dobson Blast Off the goal
post then off of heart off the post again and it
stays out send it in hoping for a bank but played
nicely by Bou he's bumped good job there that
way got it in front py shot this a made rebound
halfway pokes it free it's that there Andre keeps
it alive got it back quick shot went wide and now
it's sanheim back along to delorier Atway that's
what this line likes to do cycle down low haling
bailing holds got it to the side of it into the
blue b it away it sits in the slot back to Andre
quick pass across de on the shot blocked off Atway
Cent the shot they score Nick delar and it's tied
at one and that line continues to look good they
got some up from their defenseman in this shift as
well Nick delore wow I love this guy scores he's
he's so just loves to score loves to get in there
here's the here's the four check early in that
shift paway great play there by paling keeps the
puck alive and there's paling again taking the
puck to the net keeping things alive nice pass
by Andre over there to sanim and sticking around
that net great play there great pass pathway out
to delore I love it delore not leaving the front
of the net and gets rewarded it we've gone down
to the wire in trading camp with so many young
players pushing that's what it's supposed to be
like right yeah that's what John was saying the
other day homes from in front looking for the
tip from P it comes all the way back to Mayfield
this shot is blocked by Kate who was interfered
with but they let that one go they still get to
the buck connect for Kat he scor Noah Kat pushed
through the interference with the finish and the
Flyers with a 2-1 lead walk here fighting through
the interference like you said connecting little
backhand sash what a dish and KY there putting it
l Walker on barala man that's just great effort
putting the body on the line just great hands
there by TK getting that that puck over is connect
me try to get it back to him to many the is so
conne goes around behind but there's sealing the
pass and then the between leg I think skate is a
a media Outlet it was your first there you go yeah
you you got to you know come to camp in shape you
got to be on your toes you got to anticipate
and and D did a great job of of doing all all
those things and more there especially on that
chck under away here in Period number two pass
TI close to the corner now back this way bman
got it to the point B Du and now magia with a
shot blocked up high by yor AJ Jo gets it back to
Balou This Way Big Shot from go hit the crossbar
and went out of play heard the ping only one guy
excuse me there's a onetime right off the top of
the crossbar and goes into the net getting a great
screen in front there but Hardart's trying to find
that puck he knows it's coming and just doing
a great job and again if you joined us late he
was not expected to play tonight but rashm was
the line and was scratched here's tippet getting
behind the defense and on go save re he [Applause]
scores oh and tiin Rams home the rebound 3-1
Philadelphia that's great play Here by Sim
moving the puck up there's Frosty with that
beautiful pass and there's the speed FS right
there following up that shot getting the rebound
and elevating it that's an unbelievable job by the
guys moving the puck from their own Zone deep in
your own Zone getting the puck moving through
the neutral zone can head up 17 seconds on the
power play F looks to the net and fires and the
save byov and it goes out of play there's the
space for Joel F to get going north absolutely
rip that one I'd love to see someone in front
of lov's eyes they're taking that ainson and cou
ainson moves out now going to rotate out down to
48 seconds on the twom man Advantage they're very
patient York in front connect these SCS and that
patience pays off Connect me the power play goal
4-1 Philadelphia the penalty killers there look
how far they are apart and there it is almost
like a two on0 from this is what you practice
every day in practice when you're shooting on
goenda to high right in the middle of slot and
TK Li in Sixers Seasons just about to start and
so the third period commences Flyers held the
Islanders without a shot for the final 841 of that
second three hailing check here and the Islanders
try to maneuver back pno is dumped by paling as he
plays it in that puck took a strange hop by cter
he's now caught in no man's land in front it goes
and Pino scores their first shot in about a half
a period of hockey but it's in the net after the
giveaway by Carter hard the puck took a strange
hop on him behind the net and he never recovered
42 just talking about Good handles by Carter har
with this defenseman Did It Was a Rolling Puck
took a weird kick off the the Dasher there and
and I think you could have scored that one JJ
with an empty net like that I would have gotten
there but uh no but unfortunate bounce there for
carer he's had such a solid game move in that
puck getting out there stopping the puck setting
him up for his demand and that one keman stopped
on a good read by Cur it's like having a third
defenseman out there C always in good position
here's a turnover by the Islanders Frost jumps
on it frost surging on in Frost the pass the shot
they score great setup by Frost Atkinson pounds
at home 52 Philadelphia it's been broke a stick
there on that clearing play right there broke in
half so you had to toss it just a great pass right
pass the sliding defenseman just good speed there
good awareness of what's going on around you and
Cam's not going to missing any of those right
in the back from the net [Music] so wow right
through Escape just unable to get the tip there
Mor Frost has tremendous Poise with the puck look
out here though and they tip it past him in I goio
gloves save carart flashes the leather to keep the
Flyers up by three and Andre will play it back to
Center York on it there plays it in and that'll
do it for the Flyers pre season strong ending
as cter har packs outs the FES to a 52 victory